dans l'entretien publié par le journal
le figaro du 26 mars vous déclarait nous
regrettons que le rapport définitif ne
soit ni rendue publique ni mise à la
disposition des parties prenantes les
autres auditionné hier la ministre
déléguée chargée l'autonomie qui nous a
déclaré que le gouvernement souhaitait
rendre public le rapport igas igf mais
que cela n'était pas possible du fait de
l'opposition d'orpea opposition réitéré
dans un échange de courriels entre la
miss et le groupe que nous avons eu de
la part la ministre ce matin ma question
est simple la société orpea
autorise-t-elle la publication du
rapport de la mission igas igf sur la
gestion des établissements d'hébergement
de personnes âgées dépendantes du groupe
orpea je vous demande oui ou non
simplement
monsieur le sénateur bernard m bernard
bonne bien sûr que oui nous n'avons
jamais sollicité la non publication de
ce rapport jamais
écouté je crois que les choses sont
claires c'est s'est dit sous serment
donc ça veut dire que des deux mains le
rapport plus pour être publié enfin en
respectant bien entendu de secret des
affaires o le secret safer vous savez
monsieur le sénateur se limite tout
simplement à ce qui relève du droit de
la concurrence un exemple simple nous
n'allons pas mettre le détail de tous
nos contrats oui mais mais tout le reste
mérite absolument tête largement
diffusée très bien mais je vous remercie
si une précision à comptant alors
maintenant aux subventions
[Musique]